es geht los nach fast zehn jahren ohne
die möglichkeit menschen ins all zu
fliegen aus den usa hat spacex jetzt
alle voraussetzungen erfüllt es steht
den bemannten flug der crew decken
kapsel zur internationalen raumstation
nichts mehr im weg und der starttermin
ist auch schon absehbar klicks und
science fiction
hier gibt es spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen jetzt ist der
weg in den weltraum freiem
us-unternehmen spacex hat die sicherheit
seiner crew dragon -kapsel jetzt mit
einer geplanten explosion final getestet
und das ganze lief erfolgreich dazu
brachte eine falcon 9 rakete an dragon
raumschiff auf eine höhe von 40
kilometern
dann wurde ein notfallsignal im
bordcomputer eingespielt und damit auch
der befehl das system für den notfall
triebwerke zu aktivieren und die
haupttriebwerke abzuschalten
die treibstofftanks wurden unter druck
gesetzt die triebwerke gezündet und die
crew dragon mit ihrem notfall antrieb
von der rakete weg gesteuert
letztendlich landete die dragon dann
neun minuten nach dem start im atlantik
vor der küste floridas und zwar mit
seinen vier fallschirm und genau die
hatten in der vergangenheit probleme
gemacht dem testflug am von sonntag
waren 88 flugtests einzelner fallschirme
vorausgegangen zudem fanden auch noch
zehn tests mit jeweils vier fallschirm
statt einer rekordzahl sogar für die
nasa selbst der explosions test sollte
offenbar ob die kapsel im fall der fälle
für die besatzung sicher ist und ja die
raumkapsel aber eindeutig gezeigt dass
sie im zitat unwahrscheinlichen fall
eines notfalls während des fluges sicher
von der rakete getrennt und zur erde
zurückkehren könne so die nasa analysen
zufolge lagen die maximalen
beschleunigungskräfte bei 3,5 de das ist
das 3,5 fache der erdanziehungskraft und
das entspricht nur der hälfte der
beschleunigung die die besatzung im
herbst 2008 10 bei der flucht von einer
sojus-rakete überstehen musste heißt
also die belastung der astronautinnen
astronauten kann so niedrig wie möglich
gehalten werden
der ganze test erfolgte unter widrigen
bedingungen denn er fand an dem punkt
der flugbahn statt an dem die kräfte des
luftwiderstandes am größten sind so
wurde das flucht manöver also
nochmal erschwert und so zeigte sich
auch ihren mast selbst äußerst happy so
weit wir das beurteilen können handelt
es sich um eine perfekte mission es lief
so gut wie man es nur erwarten kann und
das ist toll
zur großen überraschung aller blieb ein
bauteil bei der explosion sogar intakt
das normalerweise im orbit bleibt und
verglüht ein service modul namens trank
es befindet sich unter der kapsel und
stabilisiert diese außerdem versorgte
sie mit energie aus solarzellen und
verfügt über heizelemente dem trank
widmete ihm us sogar einen eigenen post
dragon trank fromm in flight test ist in
surprisingly good shape dennoch wird es
sich beim trank weiter um ein einweg
teil handeln auch wenn space ex viele
raketen bauteile wieder verwendet
normalerweise verbleibt der trank
nämlich im orbit und verglüht der test
zeigt dass den usa nichts mehr im weg
steht selbst astronautinnen und
astronauten zur internationalen
raumstation iss zu bringen und genau das
ist der große wunsch und auch die nasa
hat großes interesse daran
denn seit dem ende ihrer space shuttles
ist sie auf russland angewiesen um zur
iss zu gelangen
und es geht natürlich noch um mehr mit
diesen kapseln soll dann der mond wieder
erobert werden und es soll noch weiter
zum mars gehen dazu nasa chef jim
brittens sein
mit diesem kritischen test stehen wir
kurz davor selbst astronauten in
amerikanischen raumschiffen und mit
hilfe amerikanischer raketen von
amerikanischem boden aus zu starten und
die beiden astronauten doug hurley und
robert banken verfolgten die geplante
selbstzerstörung natürlich mit riesigen
interesse denn sie stehen schon bereit
für den ersten bemannten flug von spacex
2 ss dazu dr
die letzten tage waren eine unglaubliche
erfahrung für uns heute haben wir etwas
gesehen von dem wir hoffen dass es
niemals verwendet werden muss doch klar
ist auch es kann leben retten es war
eine menge arbeit nötig aber wir können
es kaum erwarten bald zur raumstation zu
gelangen das ganze projekt gehört mit
zum sogenannten commercial crew programm
der nasa bei der private unternehmen
astronautinnen und astronauten in den
erdorbit bringen sollen sowohl sp 6 als
auch boeing waren bereits 2014 damit
beauftragt worden raumschiffe für diesen
zweck zu entwickeln eigentlich sah der
ursprüngliche plan vor dass raumschiffe
bereits 2017 menschen zur iss bringen
sollten
doch das ziel rückte immer weiter in die
ferne da die sicherheit der
satzung nicht gewährleistet werden
konnte probleme gab es zuletzt beim
starliner von boeing
wir hatten darüber hier bei pixum
science fiction berichtet die kapsel
hatte auf dem weg zur iss ihre düsen zu
einem falschen zeitpunkt aktiviert grund
dafür ein timing fehler so gelangte die
unbemannte kapsel in die falsche
umlaufbahn und verfehlte die iss als
ziel boeing hat demnach gang aber betont
dass die kapsel dennoch sicher gewesen
sei und auch bei spacex gab es probleme
zuletzt explodierte eine kuh dragon bei
einem test genau der notfall triebwerke
die explodierten nämlich die jetzt die
rettung der kapsel ermöglicht hatten
damals war treibstoff durch ein
undichtes ventil entwichen und hat in
die kapsel
vor der zündung in brand gesetzt das
bauteil wurde jetzt ersetzt und zigfach
getestet es funktioniert wie sich jetzt
auch beim finalen letzten test bewiesen
hat auch für deutschland ist das nasa
projekt entscheidend dazu ein
mitarbeiter der europäischen
weltraumorganisation esa die die schmidt
in einem interview mit der bild für uns
ist das sehr wichtig weil unsere
nächsten esa astronauten entweder auf
dem boeing starliner oder dem space
extraction fliegen werden auch der
deutsche astronaut matthias maurer wird
eine von diesen beiden raketen nehmen
nach plänen der nasa und der
europäischen weltraumorganisation esa
soll auf die russische sojus-rakete dann
nur noch im notfall zurückgegriffen
werden und der termin für den ersten
start der kollegen mit besatzung ist
jetzt absehbar und ihnen masse wird die
kapsel im februar bereits fertig sein
allerdings rechnet er mit dem start im
zweiten quartal also zwischen april und
juni fielen us-rakete erste bilder des
prototypen aufgetaucht anklicken
anschauen und egis kosmos neu bei
unserem wissenschafts netzwerkes 1054
und super cool abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran